vous avez gagné on est confiné vous avez
un serait un plat confinement m'avait
bien harceler pour celui là
bon alors y'a pas les lumières rouges
n'y a pas d'ambiance un peu critique
quand je suis seule au studio mais
dialysés soir qu'ils font peur
alors l'histoire n'ont aucun rapport et
que vous confient demande simplement
parce qu'il ya pas eu de confinement
dans le passé par contre dans la tête le
droit dans un deux ou trois mois à des
trucs horreurs qui se sont passés
pendant le confinement j'ai pas à ben ça
veut dire des jambes et que les autres
matches qu'ils ont je n'ai pas de nous
réjouissons pas c'est parti pour trois
nouvelles histoires flippante ya pas de
blabla on commence tout de suite avec
celle de mme elhady ya deux ans mélanie
elle fait du house sitting pour un coût
plus âgés c'est à dire qu'elles gardent
leurs maisons quand ils partent en
vacances ou quand ils ont un déplacement
professionnel
cette fois ci c'est un scénario de rêve
c'est à dire que le couple veut partir
en vacances à hawaï deux semaines mais
ne veut pas emmener leur chat avec eux
ils ont donc besoin de quelqu'un pour
garder leur maison et surtout leurs
chats et les nourrir et mélanie ayant
pas mal discuté avec eux ayant partagé
avec eux son souhait d'aller vivre en
californie et ben bingo mélanie peut
garder les chats du couple gratuitement
et le couple peut partir en vacances
sachant que leur chat sera bien traitée
par une connaissance à l ai rejoint donc
dans leur maison en californie quelques
jours avant qu'ils partent à hawaï et
vont lui faire visiter un peu la vie lui
présenter la maison lui expliquer
comment nourrir les chats et comment
bien s'occuper d'eux et il insiste sur
le fait qu'il ya l'un des deux chaque
extrêmement timide qui est presque
farouche et du coup il lui conseille de
ne pas trop l'approché ne pas trop
forcer le contact parce que il est pas
très amical
le jour j mélanie les conduit donc à
l'aéroport et le couple est cool
puisqu'il lui laisse même les clés de
leurs deux voitures
sympa c'est donc le début des deux
semaines de garde entre guillemets pour
mélanie et donc elle est dans une maison
très grande avec deux voitures à sa
dispo et doit juste nourrir des chats
bref le rêve elle en profite pour
visiter
elle part se balader à san francisco à
sonoma monterrey bref elle aussi elle en
vacances finalement gratuite mais je
vous rappelle c'est une vidéo serait
d'horreur pour laurent tout est cool ça
fait du bien n'est ce pas attendez un
jour vers la moitié de la seconde
semaine donc on est aux trois quarts du
voyage mélanie rentrer à la maison comme
d'habitude sauf que elle a un très
mauvais film
elle sent vraiment pas bien comme si son
corps lui disais n'en reste pas là tu es
en danger vous connaissez suivi les
rôles où il est horrible sauf que là ya
aucune raison de ressentir ça une fois
dans la maison elle se force à ignorer
le fait qu'elle se sent vraiment sous
tension et pour se changer les idées
elle commence à se préparer à manger il
n'y a rien d'étrange elle commence à
sentir un peu mieux elle décide donc
d'aller se coucher pour se remettre les
idées en place il ya rien de mieux et
petite surprise en arrivant dans sa
chambre le chat timides se trouve cette
fois sous le lit de la chambre d'amis de
la chambre dans laquelle mélanie d'or
elle explique que c'est la première fois
qu'elle le voit en dix jours ce chat là
parce qu'habituellement il
l'entièreté de son temps dans la chambre
du couple le lendemain matin ce sont
toujours bizarre mais voilà il suit les
plans qu'elle avait prévu pour la
journée elle n'a pas gâché ces derniers
jours de vacances elle profite
elle décide donc de prendre la voiture
et d'aller un petit festival de musique
avait ensuite d'aller faire du shopping
bref une journée qu'elle décrit comme
génial du moins avant qu'elle rentre à
la maison
ce soir-là mélanie fini par aller se
coucher après avoir regardé un film en
se rendant dans sa chambre le chat
timide est de nouveau sous son lit elle
voit clairement qu'il n'est pas content
de l'avoir mais qu'il n'a pas envie de
quitter la chambre
le lendemain matin mélanie elle se sent
encore plus mal que la veille elle a des
nausées
elle a des courbatures bref elle a
aucune envie de sortir sauf que la
journée passe et que plus elles passent
plus mélanie à ce sentiment de malaise
qu'elle a déjà eu plusieurs fois mais là
en plus de ça elle a l'impression d'être
observés voilà là il tombe dans le truc
vraiment pas cool ou telle impression
quelqu'un te regarder ces c'est horrible
au milieu de l'après midi son état se
détériore elle est encore plus mal elles
se sont encore plus observé elle décide
d'aller prendre l'air et de se dégourdir
un peu pour penser à autre chose et
sortir de cette spirale et n'ayant plus
trop de provisions elle décide d'aller
faire des petites courses voilà et
acheter des trucs un peu soft pour pas
qu'elle ait des nausées parce qu'elle
comprend pas ce qui se passe mais les
pas bien elle se dit que c'est peut-être
un début de gastro un début d'angine
récents débuts d'une maladie à la con et
elle veut du coup vraiment prendre des
trucs simples pour son corps après avoir
payé à la caisse la caissière lui dis
gentiment bonne journée madame et la
mélanie elle fond en larmes
elle explique qu'en fait quand la
caissière lui a dit bonne journée elle a
eu la sensation que c'était la dernière
personne de sa vie qui lui souhaiterait
une bonne journée elle retourne donc à
sa voiture mais ses courses dans le
coffre et là il ya vraiment ce mauvais
feeling est là et qui lui dit ne
retourne pas dans cette [ __ ] de maison
sauf qu'elle doit s'occuper des chats
elle doit aller nourrir et elle veut
surtout pas trahir la confiance que le
couple a placés en elle
en lui confiant leur maison pendant deux
semaines elle est donc elle va juste
retourner à la maison pour nourrir les
chats etc après ça elle ira cette fois
dormir dans un hôtel
arrivée devant la maison impossible de
rentrer elle arrive pas elle a plus que
jamais cette sensation malaise cet
instinct qui lui dit fais gaffe tu es en
danger et du coup elle a une idée et
elle se dit que cette fois elle va
rentrer dans la maison et qu'elle va
hurler qu'elle vient d'appeler la police
qui sont en route et que la personne qui
se trouve ici ferait mieux dégager avant
de se faire arrêter
why not ça peut te rassurer au pire tu
t'es juste affiché de vente et chat tu
t'en fous eh bien devinez quoi à la
seconde où me lanier a fini sa phrase la
lumière de la chambre
couple s'allume et mélanie entend départ
elle a enfin des preuves qui confirment
cette sensation qu'elle a depuis des
semaines
et du coup elle sort en courant de la
maison et elle se précipite sur son
téléphone pour bien entendu appelé la
police ce qu'elle n'avait pas fait je
vous rappelle que c'était du bluff mais
ben ali croyez pas elle attend alors
dans sa voiture jusqu'à l'arrivée des
policiers
et en arrivant maya personnes vous savez
très bon ça se passe les policiers
rentrent dans la maison inspectent
toutes les pièces et il ya personne mais
la porte fenêtre de la chambre du couple
est ouverte
d'ailleurs ironie mélanie en plein moins
stressé quand même contente parce que
les portes sont ouvertes mais les chats
sont dans la maison et n'ont pas profité
pour se barrer elle veut vraiment pas
trahir la confiance de scoop c'est beau
on veut tous une maladie pour garder
notre jeu soit dans la chambre du couple
les policiers retrouvent du coup des
sachets nourriture dans un coin qui
montre qu'il ya bel et bien quelqu'un
qui avait été là mais cette personne n'a
apparemment rien volé à la donc
confirmation qu'il y avait un mec était
là depuis au moins deux jours et qui a
fait très peur aux chats timide de part
sa présence le ch a donc choisi mais la
nier c'est pour ça qu'il dormait sous le
lit de mélanie depuis 48 heures les
policiers n'ayant aucune preuve
d'entrée par effraction n'y a rien qui a
été forcée rien qui est cassé a expliqué
mélanie qui peuvent rien faire et qui
vont juste patrouille et de temps en
temps au tour de la maison voir s'ils
voient quelque chose d'anormal mais ça
s'arrête là mais je vous rappelle que
mme elhady doit encore garder la maison
et les chars pendant trois jours et
c'est ce qu'elle va faire
et elle explique que l était angoissé à
mort même si c'est rien passé la
personne n'est parvenu à elle était dans
un stress total et que depuis ce jour là
ça l'a un peu traumatisé sur ça et
maintenant quand elle part en vacances
dans une maison ou dans une chambre
d'hôtel ou quoi elle a un toc et avant
de se coucher elle vérifie l'intégralité
de l'appartement de la maison de la
chambre d'hôtel pour être sûr qu'il ya
bien personne et qu'elle est seule
malgré tout elle est vraiment contente
que son instinct et pris le dessus
ce jour là et quels effets choix de
rentrer en hurlant et en menaçant la
potentielle personnes qui se trouvaient
là parce que si elle n'avait pas fait ça
bah c'est pas ce qui se serait passé
voilààààà les horribles celle là je la
déteste cette histoire c'est bon j'ai
maintenant vous raconter l'expérience un
peu horrible de lucic est beaucoup plus
courte que celle de mélanie mais qui moi
m'a glacé le sang c'est un peu ma
hantise en fait bref l'histoire a lieu
quelques années avant que l'uci nous la
raconte à cette période là elle est
encore à l'université elle a un petit
afa côté elle bosse dans une animalerie
spécialisée dans les poissons d'eau
salée et les reptiles
alors on est d'accord les animaleries
c'est vraiment pas au fond bien être
animal
mais là n'est pas le débat elle explique
donc que c'était pas du tout étrange que
régulièrement des genres entre dans le
magasin des amateurs en reptiles ou en
poisson et pose des tas de questions au
staff avant de faire le pas et peut-être
de se rendre compte
lucie ça fait à peu près un an qu'elle
bosse là dedans elle est donc bien calé
en reptiles et en poissons et là il ya
une personne qui commence à se rendre
régulièrement à la boutique est apposée
à lucie des questions sur les dragons
barbu je trouve ça drôle comme l a dit
c'était fréquente des gens viennent et
posent des questions ils repassent pour
poser d'autres questions donc au début
rien d'alarmant elle répond à ces
questions pendant une heure et demie il
ya aucun problème sauf qu'après deux
fois une heure et demie de réponses à
des questions le mec continue de venir
et continue de demander des infos sur
les dragons barbu à ce stade normalement
un humain normal il ne fait plus chier
la vendeuse et il va acheter une
encyclopédie sur les dragons barbu
directement lui continue de venir et
continue de parler spécifiquement à lui
si à force de venir
ce gars-là connaît du coup l'emploi du
temps de lui si il sait à quelle heure
elle est à la boutique à quelle heure
elle n'y est pas et va donc continuer de
venir la voir tous les jours pendant pas
mal de jours sauf que des fois l'uci à
la boutique elle est seule et oui une
boutique il ya des horaires et des jours
où il ya peu de clients et du coup le
responsable décide de mettre qu'un seul
vendeur en boutique parce qu'à pas
besoin de plus pour faire des économies
sauf que quand la vendeuse c'est lucie
et qu'elle se retrouve seul face à ce
mec elle est pas très sereine et
parallèlement ce gala entre deux trois
questions sur l'accouplement des dragons
barbu et cas des petites phrases un peu
dérangeante à lucile genre sinon t'es
encore le meygal ourquoi clairement et
lucie se défend lui disant non vraiment
je suis pas intéressé et en plus j'ai un
petit ami ce qui est fort elle a pas du
tout de petite amie à l'époque et un
jour ce gars arrivent en magasin sauf
que lui si elle est dans la salle de
repas des employés et il se met à la
chercher on a donc définitivement la
preuve qu' il vient là juste pour lui
parler à elle et il s'en fout
complètement des dragons barbus ou des
poissons la manade juste de lui s'il
comprend que le gars est définitivement
celle où est elle sort de la boutique en
lui disant stop arrête de venir tu
deviens creepy malgré tout le gars va
continuer de venir tous les jours et va
continuer de demander à voir lui si à
chaque fois qu'il vient qui n'est jamais
en boutique quand le gars arrive puisque
ça manager's se met à la défendent
et du coup elle lui dit d'aller dans la
salle de repas dès qu'elle aperçoit le
gars dans la rue bref tout ça dure
longtemps lui s'il en a marre et du coup
elles deux missions elle quitte le taf
le dit vas-y râle custom est à peu près
un mois plus tard lucie et avec son père
devant la télé elle regardait news et
quelle surprise
elle reconnaît à la télé le gars chelou
et il est tout simplement en train de se
faire escorter par la police hors d'une
maison qui apparemment est celle de son
ex copine et les news explique en fait
l'ex deux gars ne s'étant pas présentés
au travail depuis un moment ils ont donc
appelé la police pour leur demander
d'aller jeter un coup d'oeil à son
domicile voir si elle va bien et il
retrouve la propriétaire de la maison
l'ex copine du match
dans sa baignoire dans une bâche est en
fait ce gala était cannibales et avait
cuisiné des parties du coeur du foie et
du cerveau de son ex copine est ce que
c'est bon pour vous je peux pas dire
c'est bon pour vous plus fort que cela
est en fait ça c'est une vraie histoire
ya eu pas mal d'articles campagne est
pas mal d'interviews de journaliste est
tout au sujet de ce gala est en fait il
a toujours plaidé la possession
démoniaque comme défense et du coup lui
si ça lui fait vachement les boules et à
la peur parce que ce gars là est venu
plein de fois la boutique elle a
constaté qu'ils étaient mes gars bizarre
et qu'apparemment il est pas seulement
bizarre apparemment ils mangent des
humains c'est bon elle a donc fréquenter
malgré elle un [ __ ] de cannibales
meurtrier pendant des semaines quoi sur
son lieu de travail c'est horrible tout
cela nous amène à la dernière histoire
l'histoire de stéphane qui n'a rien à
voir il ya pas de cannibales ya des gens
chez nous il n'ya pas deux cannibales
stéphane explique qu'il a grandi dans
l'ohio dans les années 70 et qu'avec un
ami à lui qui s'appelle johnny passé
énormément de temps dehors son pote jo
vivait dans une ferme à l'époque au bord
d'une route et les parents de stéphane
souvent le déposer chez jo et du coup il
passé une bonne partie de la journée
dans les bois a kiffé ambiance un peu
scouts
bref le temps passe il arrive aux années
lycée les fameuses et il se met à mettre
en place un truc qu'ils appellent le
stand by me un truc base et donc sur le
film du même nom qui est sorti à
l'époque l'idée c'est donc de parcourir
à pied les voies ferrées du pays sauf
que au lieu d'espérer tombés sur un
cadavre comme c'est le cas dans le film
je crois il espère juste trouver des
spots cool pour pêcher ou camper
évidemment ils ont conscience que ça
peut être dangereux mais se disent vas-y
on n'a qu'une vie on est jeune c'est des
ados et du coup ils vont quand même au
bout de l'idée ils sont donc allés au
bout des choses ils l'ont fait pas mal
de fois et tout s'est très bien passé
ils ont passé de bons moments ils sont
tombés sur des rivières il découvrait
des ponts sur lesquels personne n'était
jamais allé y pêcher il se cacher dans
les trains bref il précise que vraiment
ils ont eu aucune mauvaise expérience
tout s'est toujours bien passé c'était
idyllique
bref c'était la grande époque de
l'amitié entre stéphane et joe
malheureusement à la fin du lycée leurs
chemins se sont séparés comme ça arrive
très souvent parce qu'ils ont fait des
études différentes mais il reste tout de
même en contact et essaie de se voir dès
que c'est possible et un jour c'est le
cas un été au milieu des années 90 il se
retrouvait tous les deux dans leur ville
natale pendant une semaine
il passe donc leur journée chacun avec
leur famille mais le soir ils se
retrouvent les deux pour parler de
l'époque des bonnes expériences du lycée
bref un soir il reparle du coût des
moments il faisait des stand by me très
nostalgique vis-à-vis de cette époque et
en plus ayant quelques bières d'emmener
comme il le dit stéphane ils se disent
méfiants le reflet c'était trop bien il
se fixe donc une date un soir pour faire
ça le jour j ils demandent à leurs
femmes de les déposer à l'endroit où ils
avaient l'habitude
l'époque de commencer leur stand by me
histoire d'avoir une bonne grosse dose
de nostalgie
ils vont carrément même endroit il
explique évidemment que leur femme leur
disent les gars vous avez plus 15 ans là
il faut grandir mais joyce stéphane ans
dément pas et veulent revivre ce truc
qui faisait à l'époque et en raison
tellement raison
bref leur femme et dépose ils se
retrouvent tous les deux au point départ
habituel et la jo a une idée il propose
collier de prendre la direction qui
prenait à l'époque ils prennent cette
fois la direction opposée pour découvrir
des nouveaux lieux une nouvelle ambiance
peut-être qu'est-ce qu'on peut être
concorde entre nous les gars bref la
journée se passe bien il marche c'est
amusant c'est un peu triste aussi parce
qu'ils sont pris nostalgie et est
comment dire ce truc là témoigne du
temps qui est passé et tu as et se
disputent un la vie n'est pas infinie
sortez les violons et un peu avant que
la nuit tombe et trouver un endroit cool
pour camper c'est une zone boisée
épaisse avec des arbres de part et
d'autre de la voie ferrée donc quand tu
es sur la voie ferrée était un peu
l'impression d'être dans un tunnel
bref il commence à monter le camp en
raison d un mag du coup pour dormir dans
de bonnes conditions mais décide quand
même de checker un peu le périmètre
avant de poser leurs hamacs et c'est
pour être sûrs qu'ils sont pas à côté
d'une habitation d'une zone privée et
qui sont donc pas à deux doigts de
camper sur le terrain de quelqu'un et il
tombe sur une petite colline donc y vois
pas ce qu'il ya derrière et décide du
coup d'aller en haut de cette petite
colline pour être sûr qu'il n'y a pas
juste là la maison quelqu'un et qui sont
en train de déranger ce mec est arrivé
en haut de la colline et voit au loin un
bâtiment vieux est abandonné il voit
personne c'est calme ya aucun bruit il
ya aucune lumière mais étant bien éduqué
il décide quand même de descente du coup
de l'autre côté de la colline pour se
rapprocher du bâtiment et être sûrs qu'à
personnes callen et petite surprise
c'est en fait une vieille église
abandonnée ils la décrivent comme un
bâtiment trapu un truc à fait c'est avec
des planches de bois quasiment noir à
cause de la l'humidité et la moisissure
il ya de la mouche est la pourriture
bref c'est clairement vieux et instable
et il voit qu'en fait dedans il ya
toujours tous les bancs bien en place et
une sorte de petite estrade sur laquelle
peut se placer quelqu'un qui parle au
potentiel gens qui assurent le bon bref
stéphane et jo ça leur suffit ils n'ont
pas voulu non plus rentrer checker tout
en détails y retournent à leur campement
la nuit tombe et joey stéphane entendent
des bruits en provenance de l'église
c'était sûr oui je sais tous deux
sortent alors de leurs hamacs et
commencent à avancer accroupi vers le
haut de la colline pour avoir un visuel
sur l'église et ils entendent bel et
bien un champ il arrive alors en haut de
la colline et sont allongés et cette
fois il ya malheureusement de la lune
r dans l'église ils voient ça ils se
disent c'est quoi ce bordel et le chant
c'est un chant effectivement religieux
un chant typique de ce qu'on peut
entendre les églises mais c'est dans une
autre langue
c'est à dire qu'il ne distingue aucun
mot dans le son et reconnaissent rien
après un petit moment de silence il y a
une voix masculine qui se remet à
chanter juste une voix et un moment tous
les gens qui se trouvent dans l'église
se mettent à répéter les mots que dit la
voix masculine
un peu comme dans les films savez qu'il
ya une c'est qu'il ya des chants et il
ya toujours un leader qui chante et la
foule d'adhérents qui répète ce que dit
le leader
bref ce petit jeu de ping pong devient
de plus en plus forts de plus en plus
dérangeant et stéphane se met les mains
sur les oreilles et finit par dire à jo
mais qu on se casse et joe lui réponds
oui
ça tombe bien parce que là ils sortent
et voit au loin une file de personnes
qui se tiennent par la main en file
indienne sortir de l'église certains
d'entre eux ont des lampes torches et il
se met à tourner en main dans la main en
chantant toujours de plus en plus fort
sauf que ceux qui ont des lampes torches
et claire les environs et éclaire sans
faire exprès nos amis joe et stephan
joho et stéphane se chie dessus ils se
lavent et partent en courant en
direction de leur campement ils rangent
leurs affaires en un temps record et ils
prennent en sens inverse le chemin
qu'ils avaient emprunté la journée
d'avant pour retourner là où leurs
femmes les avait déposées mais les
lumières s'agit de manière erratique
comme si les personnes qui tenait les
lampes torches les secoués dans tous les
sens et réalise qu'en fait c'est pas que
les personnes qui tiennent les lampes
torches lescout dans tous les sens c'est
qu'elles sont en train de courir vers
eux stéphane et joe continue donc à
sprinter à faire des pauses à sprinter à
faire des pauses bref il rêve juste de
remonter dans la voiture de leur femme
et après plusieurs minutes il arrive sur
une route et ils voient qu'ils ne sont
plus suivis à plumergat heureux et
décide alors à l'aide de leur carte de
se rendre dans une petite ville qui se
trouvait à 15 minutes de là où ils
étaient arrivés sur place ils se rendent
à une station-service de la ville ouvert
24 heures sur 24
ils appellent leurs femmes pour leur
dire venez nous chercher on a à tel
endroit on vient du un truc chelou
tout s'est bien passé leurs femmes sont
donc venus les chercher et du coup ils
ont raconté l'histoire à leurs proches
et leurs proches leur ont dit que
c'était sûrement des gamins qui se
regroupaient pour se faire peur pour
faire des blagues
sauf que joy stéphane ils ont entendu
des voix et s'était pas du tout des
champs amateurs et des blagues c'était
un truc avait l'air très sérieux et
finit donc en disant qu'il sait pas qui
étaient ces gens il sait pas ce qu'ils
faisaient là bas mais que c'était le
truc le plus [ __ ] de flippant qu'il
ait vu de toute sa vie tout finit bien
et donc je trouve c'était juste des gens
d'une secte en fait qu'ils se rendaient
la bac avait une sorte de rituel ou
juste des faits les fins bref il sait
pas trop et il n'a pas du tout envie de
savoir hockey et nous non plus
d'ailleurs
c'est la fin de ce serait d'horreur je
me souviens du bon j'ai pas mis trop de
trucs intrusion parce que comme on est
tout le temps chez nous en ce moment
c'est pas le moment
de parano vis-à-vis de ça je trouve suis
particulièrement sensible à cette
mécanique horrible du compte a été en
contact avec quelqu'un et que tu
apprends par la suite que ce quelqu'un
avait un vrai problème et était vraiment
très dangereux sont ça vraiment horrible
tout astruc de trahison c'est horrible
j'espère que ça vous aura plu moi
j'adore ces trois histoires les trois
personnes vont bien et d'ailleurs dans
la première histoire mélanie elle
précise que depuis qu'elle a posté sur
le forum elle a reçu beaucoup beaucoup
de soutien de gens du coup elle était
hyper contente et voilà elle a envoyé un
message d'amour derrière aux gens donc
voilà on finit quand je serai dans le
positif parce que là on est en pls à
l'essai chao ses bonnes nuits au revoir
[Musique]